[Music]
and you're probably with that blonde
girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure
about olivia rodrigo's latest single
driver's license
dropped over the weekend and now fans
think the track is about her reported
ex joshua bassett and his rumored new
boo
sabrina carpenter so you you recorded an
ep in quarantine
what's the update is this out yet no
that means so much to me and that i love
so much and
the fact that people like listened to it
and liked it it's just icing on the cake
e.t has reached out to a rep for olivia
but in the meantime
let's take a closer look olivia and josh
star alongside each other in the disney
plus high school musical reboot
and play two high schoolers in love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and while the high school musical the
musical the series co-stars never
confirmed in
off-screen romance their on-screen
chemistry
instagram activity and affinity for
writing music together broken
[Music]
led fans to believe they had a thing
going on off screen
i think a big reason that i grew so much
is because i
met joshua who is obviously this amazing
musician
singer-songwriter and i think before
that i had never really met
anyone that was kind of interested in
the same things that i was interested in
that was like my age
and uh that was really inspiring and i
think he really pushes me to do better
but rumors that the two split hit in
summer 2020
when olivia posted this video about
quote
failed relationships on tick tock
but this song is still free
and shared this pic with her pal iris
apatow
rocking shirts that said dump him around
that time photos of josh hanging out
with sabrina carpenter surfaced
and the two dressed as shark boy and
lava girl for halloween
hit the hay faster sleep dream a dreamy
little bleep
now fans think that her new breakup
ballad is about
all that i've got my driver's license
last week
exhibit a olivia sings about a blonde
girl who's
much older than she is and you're
probably
with that blonde girl who always made me
doubt she's so much older than me
she's everything i'm insecure about
sabrina she's both blonde and four years
older than olivia
sabrina is 21 olivia is 17.
and get this in the original version of
the song
olivia's lyrics were about that brunette
but were changed
to that blonde girl
the one i always thought about
exhibit b olivia sings this
i know we weren't perfect but i've never
felt this way for no one
and i just can't imagine
cause you didn't mean what you wrote in
that song
about me fans have speculated that
josh's 2020 song
anyone else is about olivia i am
during an interview with euphoria
magazine josh said he wrote the song
while shooting season one of their show
and he told broadway world at the time
quote i was
hopelessly falling in love with a close
friend who was in a relationship with
someone else
i think one of the things that i've
really learned from olivia is
the um the storytelling aspect of
songwriting
and i think that i you know i'm more of
like a this is how i feel in this moment
and she really does
a job of like telling a story and
putting you in that time and place and i
think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of we
you know we grow from each other i think
and there's a lot of like kind of
looking each other being like oh
wow like there's you know she still
writes a song every single day and i'm
like geez i gotta get on my game you
know so i think that it's like
it's a healthy sort of like supportive
way we're growing together in that way
since production of the disney plus show
began in early 2019
fans think these lyrics reference
olivia's relationship with ethan wacker
but when it came to the music video some
eagle-eyed fans pointed out that the
nails of the girl in the video
matched sabrina's nails in late june aka
the same time the video was most likely
[Music]
filmed
anyone else exhibit c
the driver's license music video also
shows a short clip where someone grabs
olivia's chin
this is the same video used on spotify's
selection of her song all i want
and that's josh's hand grabbing her chin
exhibit d olivia mentions seeing the
mystery man's face
in white cars and from his youtube
channel we know
josh drives you guessed it a white car
but perhaps the most important clue of
all in a resurfaced social media video
olivia revealed that josh took her
driving for the first time
an experience she said she'll always
remember
i also got the chance to co-write a song
with my co-star
joshua bassett it's called just for a
moment and i remember the day that we
found out that they
chose the song and that it was going to
be in the show we celebrated and we went
to in and out
and i couldn't drive actually i was 16
but i like didn't have
my permit and so he took me in his car
and we like drove around in and out
parking lot and that was my first time
driving so i'll always remember that
so there's that and her lyrics well just
take a listen
i've got my driver's license last week
just like
we always talked about cause you were so
excited for me to finally drive up to
your house the song's called driver's
license people
now flash forward to after the song's
release
josh and a bunch of other high school
musical the musical the series castmates
posted about the song on their insta
story
olivia shared the majority of them on
her account
but not josh's oh and sabrina's
ex-boyfriend
griffin gluck he posted about the song
too
and when some fans started to theorize
on tick tock that driver's license was
about olivia's ex ethan
he shot that down hitting up the
comments writing nope
i treated her well he even went on to
praise the song on his
insta story driver's license is
freaking amazing if you haven't heard it
listen to it already olivia
killed the song really really proud of
her it was amazing
really good